welcome to the recruitment rollercoaster
podcast my name is Hisham azuz today I'm
joined by Susan Barents who is a senior
consultant at signify technology you are
a specialist technical critten agency
Susan's were Susan works in the team of
five and has been a signifier for coming
up to three years Susan thank you for
joining me
hello thanks so much for having me on
how are you privileged good so we spoke
about this didn't we see you live on
your own in the flat yes obviously that
I would find that so tough but obviously
have you've worked out who's gonna be in
your social bubble and here you can have
overall yeah it's gonna have to be my
mom and dad be my social bubble yeah
cool well let's so as I was telling you
before we started this where I always
like to start on this show is how you
got into recruitment and as you'll know
obviously we had Ryan Adams on and I'll
see your your boss the founder
signifying a legend
yeah the legend I mean yes I mean his
story is being it's very quickly become
the most listened to be booked us on
here so I think a lot of people be
really interested to hear so your
journey in working for a leader like
that so but let's let's start how how
cuz I'll see you working it signify that
this your being your first and only
recruitment job right yeah so how did
Susan enter the world of recruitment I
feel like everyone says this but they
kind of fell into it they're always in
it and as I didn't really fall into
recruitment I fell into a state agency
which I feel like a lot of people start
off with and so was a teenager working
in a toy shop ended up managing a couple
over a couple of towns and then that toy
shop didn't work out and somebody just
went to me you know what I think you'd
be quite good at a site I didn't see I
used to do it and you'd probably be good
at it because you're gonna talk into
people so that was a I was like 19 at
the time didn't have any qualifications
or anything so I applied for your site
agencies
ended up getting a job a company called
cubit and West a really really great
company and they introduced me to the
world of sales you know ABC always be
cozy an objection handling all of that I
went for like two weeks rigorous
training in the classroom so that was I
might enter into sales really enjoyed
that job it was hard like the first six
months I think I cried every day because
I had no idea what to do lettings and
ida sales so I went straight into sales
and I learned a lot there like a lot
about resilience and yeah just going
through so I worked in not a very high
performing office so it was a struggle
just to do okay there but I had a really
good team really well you could manage a
really really good area managed as well
but what happened there was a left about
two years but everyone in my family has
gone off and gone travelling and gone
right done how I usually a thing and so
it was like in my destiny to go travel
in so at the age of like 21 I said I was
going to leave Kuban west and I travel
him so I was away for like four years
and Straley I was in New Zealand
Philippines like Southeast Asia yeah I
was gone for quite some time and when I
first started looking for a job that
only people that come back to me flat
sales companies and I was I'm not a
salesperson I don't know with his come
form why do people want with his our
jobs he just ended up that I just every
see I went to I got like proper
Commission based cold call sales jobs
that every see I was in I'll get a job
like selling food an insurance car
insurance a car in states like all of
that I probably just pick up the phone
and being told to F off every single day
and I did that it's like four years
straight just in each city I was in and
and I kind of built up more sales there
and and then I was in Sydney on a
recruitment company reached out to me at
the time I kind of knew what recruitment
was because my best friend Jack who is
actually my manager it signified believe
it or not and had been like recruiter
since he was an 18 he was always
money that I had a nice flat and I was
like I want to be successful so I got
offered a job in Sydney by recruiting
company but I was coming home like soon
after that so as soon as I got home knew
I was home for good I was like right I
want to be in recruitment definitely one
do it spoke to Jack about it and that's
when you've been it signify for just
under a year and I think he was a bit
hesitant about me working at work he's
free on-site is my best friend he's been
my best friend since we were like 15
used to each domains Oh sometimes time
he was advised me of what C recruitment
I think in the back of his head he kind
of wanted to see if I could work at
signifyd but didn't really want to offer
it he wasn't sure so I interviewed a few
places and then I was like do you think
I could maybe speak to your boss about a
job there and then we had a long chat
about like what it would be like to work
with your best friend in like a
high-pressure sales environment and
eventually use that yeah called have a
chat Ryan and I don't really go to a
trial I fell in love Ryan fell in love
with what they were doing the passion
behind every one it was a small team
then and I loved every single one of
them conversation with Ryan at the start
like here's a how you're gonna be
working so close with the best friend
means that isn't gonna affect you and I
without a good chat
I respect Jack he respects me so
absolutely how many people in the
company when you joined I was a sixth
person joined the company okay and then
we were where you guys that now we are
at 32 I believe right now so it's been
an interesting journey then right
yeah really really interesting so I mean
clearly had this or grounding of
resilience sales all that so I mean
you'd like something you'd like to think
obviously be pretty confident back in
yourself in that first year but what
went on than that so just quickly
obviously I think what was really unique
about signifies that you guys do like of
the order like a super super neat
yeah and that's the scholar right
Scarlett yes so that's that's all we do
the vision for Ryan was mentioned in
this podcast but the vision was if you
could know your one market inside out
back to from every single person then
you're going to be able to deliver the
best half as possible because you know
it all inside out and it's gonna be no
there's gonna be nothing that you don't
know so that was a vision and it just it
just worked really really well and I
think I'm very very lucky for my first
recruitment job to have been with
signified like Brandon and what the
vision we had behind the company like
the mission of the company it's just so
easy to believe in which I think has
just made the job easier to do so
what what did that firstly look like
then Susan what went on so did you did
you what was the structure was you gone
into a contract team was it perm from
the start so jack has been a contract
biller for his whole life and I
obviously went under his wing he took me
under his wing and I joined the
contracting and there was just three of
us and I was like the resort for the
tapes I just started off like a
liberator yeah just in delivery and I
had like really I say it's flew I said
it was flew to start with but Ryan keeps
telling me you can't say it's fluke but
I had a really really really good first
few months in the job that crazy good
and I started in the August and by the
end of the year just had an amazing
first four months and I was flying and I
was like this is amazing loving country
the top three in the company is amazing
got a little world and then and then
because I did so well and I'd put on a
couple of clients he promoted me to
consult and quite quickly
and so after four months I've got
promoted to kosoul which is I for 360
and that hit quite hard a thing I think
although I've done really well and I'd
walk tides I was then doing both before
I was just really sorted in roles I got
on it and
then all of sudden it was spitting a day
like having to do everything and I went
from doing really well and then I had a
couple of really rough months I just
didn't achieve anything and I was Alex
beginner's luck really really found it
so then I kind of see it separately like
my first four months from August to
December was like my trial period I say
yeah I happened to do really well and I
see my first real full year is that like
January disassembler so just quick just
quickly so this first four months yeah
let's just think about that for a sec so
see you how did you go about what was
your mindset towards learning about this
sector niche because obviously never
done that before what was your mindset
and how did you approach that and I just
listened to everything that was going on
around me and I actually had to do full
weeks of shadowing before they let me on
the phones so I did four weeks of
literally just sitting behind each of
the guys and just listening to what they
were doing and watching what they're
doing making notes and I'm tell you now
four weeks of shadowing and they're not
actually doing anything is pretty rough
might be sitting they thinking I'm gonna
fall asleep because you're not doing
anything but Ryan obviously had a plan
and it worked out because I just I must
have taken everything in and I'm
rewinding over and over again what the
techs were what they meant you know not
when you're studying for an exam and you
write stuff over in our own home can you
write again highlight it so I think I
just listened and took it all in
and every time I got off a call where
every time I finished up it up like what
could I've done differently what wasn't
right about that to the point was
constantly asking questions and
constantly asking people to like Chris
he quite done really wonderfully
interesting so what I just have
interests them what was what was the
most what was the most common thing that
you sort of went ended up and improving
on or sort of feedback you got because I
think that I mean first first I think
what's great about that is that he was
willing to take the feedback so I think
that that can be quite not everyone's up
for that
get me wrong at some points in my head
I'd be like I didn't do that badly did I
I think the main thing came when just
when I start with was to slow down what
I was doing in and then to listen like
that was the two things like slow down
the qualification but when you're
talking and stuff yeah instead of just
taking off a list of questions slow down
what you're doing and listen to what's
been said to you is as much as you can
ask a question if you're not listen to
the answers you're not getting a
qualification you're just taking some
poppers and it would be a case of I'd
get off the phone and I'd say this and
then Jack or Charlie my team would say
right but so what does what does he want
to do this
where is he want to be like they'll ask
me questions and I wouldn't have the
answers because I hadn't done the
qualification coffee so be like get back
on the phone oh hey probably gonna find
three or four times in the same time
there's nothing worse than like again
awful cool thinking and absolutely know
that and then your manager or boss well
right Susan tell me about this Bluff
back in the quarry and with you on that
something really simple like when Kenny
style anybody's really good yeah now I
think and I think it's at that beginning
you want to just I don't know yeah get
through things and I think you know I I
definitely I got that advice as well so
stop speaking too quickly and trying to
rush things but you just want to just
get more and more under your belt but I
love that well what I love about that is
and what people can take away from that
is like the quicker that you're willing
because I'd like to think Susan that
you're free is and then you know still
open for people someone's ago Susan I
think could have done that better I ask
questions all day cuz I everyone says
the saying like work smart not hard I
think you should do both but I work
smart like the people around me are
really successful so why not ask them
what they're doing all day every day
because then I'm just taking what
they're doing and I can make that my
success rather than having to my own and
I
love that I think being encouraging and
sort of having it instilled in you early
on to be like Susan how can I prove that
what could I do blah blah blah make that
okay and make that normal is exactly
what you should do
I think that's awesome so I think that
it happens quite a lot where people can
I've had it his habits being said so
many times on this podcast where
someone's had a really good couple of
first three four months and then they
just have a really rough next couple of
months right but I think so like what
was that experience like them I know so
many people sort of has gone through
that so I guess what what how do you
sort of cope with the self-doubt because
that's what happens when I could be
really careful then candidate now there
now I'm doing clients like what what was
you what was the sort of self dialog to
make sure that you carried on and then
quit I say at first I didn't cope with
it very well no it was you I'd be
confident me office but then you got
home you be I I've just I've lost it
maybe I do have as much as you can be a
competent person and if you've done so
well and then you didn't you're like oh
maybe it was just luck so yeah probably
didn't go very well of it not in the
first month or so I was like why isn't
anything turning around but I suppose I
was very lucky that the team I was in
and Ryan was so light if this happens
that this is the industry it's not you
it is the industry just keep going and
don't you do in and so I did what they
said would just keep going but the
self-doubt was still there I didn't I
mean I still doubt myself but I just
kept doing what they told me to do
because like I said before they were
successful so if I do what they say then
eventually I'll be successful also I'd
say that the south self doubt never went
at all I felt horrendous like you feel
really bad right self all the time but I
just stuck with what they told me doing
keep doing and around and so it was
pretending I was okay just do what they
do and then going home and dealing with
it when you're at home on your own and
then eventually it turned around how
long is that period you thing was
roughly four things starts really click
and you really started to build a bit
momentum I think it was I had to really
muffins like genuinely Fred berry and
then the March started turned around and
then I started getting a bit of
consistency and for that year I was like
I was on target for most of the year
I wasn't like excited I wasn't doing
crazy well but I hit my target so I was
like I was output where need is fee I
wasn't doing the crazy well so there was
there wasn't room for improvement in
consistency in being where I needed to
be I just kept going this I was at least
I'm doing something right how did you
how did you finish your first year that
[Music]
in the company was often goes fifth out
of about fifteen company one is whereas
the year before I'd finished third in
like kind of billions for the year I
don't know if you want numbers yeah yeah
we're dying to know come on yeah yeah
but in my first full month a year before
I'd finished on 130 really in four
months I've gone from like wow if I
could do that in four months next I'm
gonna do so yeah I think just under 200
and that kept me on I was on target for
you basic yeah that's awesome
so obviously been so I was a perm
recruiter so I guess from what I
understand is for you it was all about
get obviously the candidates side but
and then it's the client side this see
it's there just a challenging right but
I'll see it's you need to be
consistently getting new projects on and
then obviously the candidate piece I
feel like it's a bit easier because
there's just more free movement right
compared to perm so I guess what and
sort of the business development piece
is something that always people want to
know about so I guess what's been your
journey with getting prospects winning
projects business development as a
contract recruiter during that period
what was that like I think everyone has
their own style of me day and I think
in the kind of the contract market is
very much an elite driven environment
like contracts fast moving it's
constantly going and so I kind of don't
work on that level I love them everyone
I know it really is so like lead heavy I
still do everything on lead generation
and so on but my success has come from
just building relationships so getting a
client and then expanding in that client
as far as why I can by building the
completion ship with them so just having
one or two really big accounts at any
one time and just making sure that you
are fully delivering on them so you can
expand outwards I feel like that's
probably the way that I do things and
that's the way that I've been more
successful is by nurturing what I have
rather than constantly looking for one
little bit here and there
and so yeah my advice for anyone is
always nurture the strong ratios you've
got whether it's contract or Candida if
you are genuinely a friend of theirs and
genuinely have the rapport and you get
on then at some point they are going to
be able to help you out with with
introducing your product you know I love
that because I think it's so easy to get
caught up in need new new business new
job new project and and it's come up
quite a lot recently there actually so
like you just say that well actually
instead of having that mindset if I have
to free for good solid big accounts that
I can do I don't know 50 80 whatever
came with each there that's a good
position to be in right so I guess let's
talk about that for a second because I
think a lot of people listening will be
more of new job new business and always
a pleasure like that right and so I
guess let's just talk about what's been
Susan's approach over the last three
years on expanded in those accounts
because I think that's where some people
may not know or understand or have much
experience in actually doing so I guess
it might have happened naturally or
whatever but I guess sort of thinking
now in the last three years when you
when you have done it yeah and you put
that down to quite the big pot have you
been
successful with business development how
have you gone about expanding accounts I
think the first thing to do is when you
get on a new role or you get on a new
client they've got several roles just
deliver as best you can on what they've
given you and like I think a lot of
people try to over promise because they
want to they want to be liked and then
they think that they can deliver
I would never over promise and under
deliver because we all know recruitment
has got a stigma around it it does and
if you're causing the over-promising and
under-delivering you're kind of paying
into that stigma a little bit and so I
would just be truthful like this is what
I can actually do for you and if it
doesn't match up with their expectations
that's where a common a consultant comes
and you consult them as to why what you
do won't match their expectations but
this is what you can do and it will
maybe get the same result maybe a
different time scale or different kind
of candidate and so that's why I think
becoming a consultant comes in because
in fact the the client is gonna want one
thing if you over-promised and you can't
actually do that then they're not gonna
work with you again if you can count the
solution but you know your amount
achieve for them and actually still help
them achieve what they need on a
business side of things then once you've
done that you can then very easily say
okay do you know anyone else I can also
offer this help to is the first the
first part is make sure you can deliver
and do deliver right and that no I love
that and I think what this has come up
on before with a chap James James Dean
where like you go through that process
early on I'm like not being a yes-man
you do not I mean and like because it's
so easy to like you've got that client
going yes Susan so I've got this
requirement blah blah blah and you're
known at the back of your head there's
no way that he's gonna be able to get
this well just use me out to get this
and you just get better actually as you
said
saying no but also being a consultant
I've got more lips actually this is why
I probably say and if that means you
don't get the job that's actually a
probably a good thing but would as you
said it's then being a consultant so I
think we just said there is first first
things first don't forget
that made sure that you leave a good
impression right and you actually
deliver them so fine so we five if I've
done that like obviously besides just
the classic like who else can I have
brother blood and I what what have you
found work in terms of like I don't know
has it have you got these people then to
introduce you to other people in the
business or have you then just sort of
used them to map how sort of other parts
of the business and then you're calling
them and going hey look we haven't
spoken before but I delivered with
such-and-such on this project I don't
know what what have you found really
works I'd say I do by side it all
depends on how I feel my relationship is
with that person whether it's client or
candidate because both are just as able
to get you into a project right if
you've got a candidate days a strong
contractor has been on that team for ten
months and you've worked with them
previously if they are doing well in
their job their opinion is gotta count
so that's how I do it both and the first
first one the first sort of step I go to
is ask them directly do you know anybody
else can you introduce me if it's a
really large global company then I will
and I know my relationship with you I'm
currently working with it strong I will
do the work myself
I will go out introduce myself to other
client other parts hire managers within
the same company explain I'm already
working with Hyman explain why I've
already done for them and I already know
that that person when asked will be
happy is about me be a referral so
instead of having them to do the leg
work you do the leg work you introduce
yourselves to all the other hiring
managers within the company that you
want to help and then all you have to do
is very quickly leave them up and give
them a referral so it's almost so
they're not having to do it they don't
feel like they're part by having to do
something for you you've already done
the legwork so like that and and then
have you got better sort of I guess
identifying who could be a big account
you know I mean because I feel like
there there's obviously an element of a
bit of a plan or strategy doubt then if
you've got better sort of obviously as
you've got to know your market you part
of you exercises or part of your
strategy if you have one there's mapping
out right so I've got these big accounts
at the moment who else could be your
client like that I don't know how have
you gone about so
giving yourself the best possible chance
of that first sort of impression that
you give ends up being a bigger account
I think it's more about what the the
market at your map in everybody knows
like their bigger parts like the banks
the big media companies they know them
all but we all know that they have
massive vendors and there's there's so
much work to get through and they don't
ever really appreciate your service
because they've already got internal so
and although they are good at cuts crack
if you can fantastic but my strategies I
just look for startups that have had
funding recently had funding they've
already got a vision of what they're
very much going to be they already know
what products they need to build upon to
get the funding some they've got the
funding they've got what they need to be
built so they've got all contractors on
site ready to work but it's quite simple
so they already know now they've got the
money to do it quick get people on site
as quick as possible
and so you on them so is it part of your
week that you'll be reading industry
stuff and you get stuff emailed in to
inbox just to keep an actual eye on this
yeah and oh my god it's come from my
head that's okay but in you you answer
you have to be read industry yeah
industries and I do a lot of are
literally very simply just type into
Google top 10 tech companies funding
this month and somebody would have
written a blog somewhere it's that
simple just tech companies funding UK
and when you find these companies are
you literally then calling them going
hey seen that you Reese got funding that
is that do you so then use that as part
of the concepts of why reaching out yeah
I think it will it's not a silly but
sometimes when I look at somebody's
profile LinkedIn and who they are I kind
of try and get a feeling for how they
would like to be approached even though
that's completely on my own judgment and
sometimes it probably backfires but I
think and look at kind of where they are
in the company whether they want like a
soft approaches and introduction and we
are his liver however it's very much
this is a candidate do you want them
so that's kind of I kind of have to
figure out myself which way I'm gonna go
in or and try and keep getting touch
with people that already work in there
I mean speak tumors other candidates and
just get a feel for whether the projects
working and try and get info that way as
who the right person to speak to and
then always just refer back and said
actually smoked something in your
network they've mentioned that you are
hiring
okay so full year 360 then so was that
when you is that when you finish just on
the terms okay said is that what that
yes oh yeah yeah 360 yeah cause it
consultant yeah and then obviously and
then this and then so then and then and
then if you had another full year then I
was at this year yeah so that was last
year last year so I did four year as a
consultant and then December got
promoted to senior and then my last year
was four year as a senior last year
before this [ __ ] went down basically
yeah yeah how did that year like just to
context and Sons of billions and then we
can talk a bit about where yeah let's
talk about that I finished on 460 K last
year [ __ ] hell right so let's say
that that's the reason why let's just
put the number aside for a second the
reason why that's important it's not the
actual number itself it's more like if
you think about sort of people listening
seasoned people want to know that that's
actually possible to go from like where
you was which was just on the tool okay
so then actually hear you say well
actually it actually doubled my my
billions and more people were just as so
interesting understanding well what the
hell did you do differently tsunami so
that's why it's just important to it
just helps with context right yeah so
let's talk about that for a sec so
firstly it's a business development
clients projects would have been key to
that yeah so what did you do differently
or like did you crack some big accounts
whatever it may be but like what changed
or what did you do differently that you
think an able you to produce those
results on the on the business
development side first or change there
so the business development stuff like
having a few a few bigger parts like
going happen towards
at the end of the end of my first year
bringing them on and that was when I'd
built up my my network I bought my
rapport but never had loads of
contractors that I speaking to that
spoke to regularly
I didn't even paste most of them I just
spoke to them regularly and then a few
of them introduced me to projects they
just join in startups and companies I
have recently funded that's basically
what happened in fact my my main large
accounts haven't even come from
contractors that I've paced myself
really is that I've had I've known or
spoken to at times I've met conferences
so yeah my main accounts have come from
that just constantly keep in touch with
people and having a genuine relationship
with these people and being genuine
friends with them made it a lot easier
for them to introduce me what's helped
me as well is you get it's the advice
you're giving this like season keep them
when you're doing it'll pay off but
obviously you do have those moments
where it's like the relationships really
become fruitful that you books you spend
those a time building I think that's
really interesting actually there
because a lot of people may have come to
you Susan you're wasting their time
their lives would focus on the contracts
that you can place or whatever but
actually use cooperate in these
relationships staying in touch with
people building rapport relationships
that people didn't actually have the
real impacts on the things so just
quickly in terms of like obviously don't
want names or anything but just it'll be
good to get a bit of a picture of like
for you to produce those sorts of
numbers talking about key accounts blah
blah blah how many like clients do
revenue is working with any one time or
during that period I think that's a
really interesting thing
that's why point of a lot a lot of
people think it's always like new
business new business new clients blah
blah blah but like to produce those
types of results and outcomes like what
we talking in terms of like crying a
number of counselors or working what
working probably three or four active
accounts yeah and then like every now
and again I'd i also did bring on
parents as well even though as a
contract billowy because we were just
growing startup
still bringing home business as well so
I'd get like like a cut on that as well
so even though I wasn't working than
myself I was bringing in perm accounts
at the time but for me personally I'd
probably be managing three or four
accounts at any one time that's
interesting right so I think that's
because a lot of people season think
that to get produce those types of
results you might need 1520 clients
where what did you not mean so I think
that that's why that's interesting and
okay so let's talk about the next thing
that a lot of people love to know about
season is your structure what you do so
what did Susan the 200 capable to do and
how the cheese structure that they
compared to the season 400 k plus
building like what I don't know did you
do and have changing if in your day or
what did the typical season they look
like massively I'd say massively so I
was so scared my first year it was
really I had about 17 notepad notepad
for and this type of a day this had many
vacations Dooley's like no place who
I've got a call today you know because I
was so scared
I never stuck to any structure and every
and every month we have like an
appraisal like you normally do and I sit
down with Ryan and Jack and be like the
one thing I need to change my shot
chiller I've not got a grasp on what I'm
doing and I think I was I was like the
my normal target because I had been
enough coming in but if I'd have managed
my desk I would have got more out of it
so it was literally just about with
myself in organized you I need to change
my shots at Annie's put stuff in place
so let's talk about what did you change
result down to one notepad now on Excel
spreadsheet i pot lists and at the end
of every day I made sure my desk is
highly I've uploaded all of my
information that I need to and that I
and I end my day
there might my die structure and what
needs to be done for my typical day is
literally in the morning I go for my
inbox and I say to myself after the
morning meeting you've got 30 minutes to
go through in books
anything that's urging you get it done
anything that isn't urgent you come back
to it just before lunch and then the
morning will be always sauce in leads
and then the afternoon is chasing leads
and BD and even now I can tell you now
you know you know happens emails come in
something comes in there's a webinar and
you're thrown off and then I bring
yourself back to your structure and see
how that change money for me I've really
had to be strict my do you think now is
a big that was a big part of why you've
got more out of the efforts at least in
everything in everything analysts and
tracking it and track in last contact
and that and yeah just making sure I was
making a record of everything I've done
cuz at times I just I wouldn't even know
where nope sorta kinda are just some
work because I'd be all over the place
and then the second thing was something
really resonated with me like Ryan
always said like you've got your target
but it to be really really good you your
target shouldnt be your target you're
sure that should be double your target
or triple your target that's what your
minutes how it should be and that kind
of happened and then I set myself that
my target should be double and double or
triple what I was looking for big and
just I don't know what I can't even tell
you what I physically changed other than
the way I did my structure but then
after that I was instead of hitting my
target I was done in my target every
month and literally just changed my mind
said that you've gotta reach for more
rather than just thinking about reaching
his heart and then that's when it came
to that doubling everyone I think um I
think what's really interesting about
that is that I've had to do this for
myself since having my own business for
the last year is that a lot of new
structure was important but I actually
didn't have a structure to put things in
forget why I'm in you know I mean so
like you obviously just got [ __ ] done
major thing
happen but what you've now got even when
you do go off on a bit of a tangent
you've got something to return to you've
got a structure to put things in I think
that's just the most important thing
that actually you need to spend time on
what a good day looks like what you want
that day to look like and once you've
actually got a sort of core skeleton
there and a core structure
you've actually got something to return
to rather than just today I just making
sure happen being reactive above our
blood but if you don't actually have a
lot of structure to put things into then
you've got no hope
I don't think something as well that I
learn is I do whether I set myself
although I do say a seadoo source in the
morning and beating off then I'll do
like our sessions I'll do an hour of
this now that and something will happen
in the day that may change that so you
just touch base at lunch and at the end
of lunch I come back after lunch I think
riot is it really sit to had what I've
had pan done or is it worth changing
that to kind of help with what's just
come in so it's just about touching base
myself all the time and adjusting it to
got to go on and started doing a lot
more recently since working for him
actually because I've really struggle to
focus being on my own all day somebody
mentioned it to it it's literally put
time on your phone for an hour set
yourself a target in that hour and then
just keep checking it you know I haven't
I'm not near it and it makes you can
actually get done yeah I've done
something like that it's only I've got
an app on my phone here it's called like
focus it's called the Pomodoro effects
obviously have you seen that something
yeah so like basically you you can set a
timer and it's like here 25 minutes or
an hour whatever and then it'll go off
when you've done and you just have a
focus just for the hour that's
definitely helped me as well I think for
me it's I've yeah it's like actually a
lot blocking out specific time to do a
specific task is will always give me the
best chance of being productive as
possible I'll come in and I just I would
you job is coming up and I'll just do
that now and and someone always said to
me like is that email right now going to
help you reach your targets today
because it's not great question why are
you taking five minutes why you
focus like that right now he's not gonna
make me hit your target that you wanted
a today so it's not worth doing right
now that's such a great question to wash
yourself isn't that is that is that
gonna bring me closer to where I need to
be hit my target blah blah blah so just
quickly you met you mentioned it a bit
around the goals but I think a real
common thing Susan besides work ethic
and putting in the work is a lot of
people will say the the sort of
difference between Susan of last year
and the year just gotten is mindset that
that's really giving you the best chance
of that's been one of the biggest
changes I'm just gonna get my charge are
my laptops about to sell no is this okay
it's okay noise wasn't the same like
obviously it might be no see actually
Ryan and Carly to think big and and that
sort of just give use increase of
standards but I'm just thinking if
there's anything else mentally the sort
of you think changed all you fall of bad
things differently that you've might
have had an impact on so getting way
better or getting way better results the
mindset thing was massive for me like I
because I think I had such a good first
four months and then although my second
year was good I was expecting more for
myself and I was constantly as mindset
like it is all luck I think people go
for that all the time in recruitment
then it's just luck like it can't be
what I'm doing the easiest luck and I'd
always just realized one day it's all
gonna fall to pieces every was gonna
realize that it was all just luck and I
had that my zyk for so so long even at
the start of last year I was like it's
not it's not actually me it's just I'm
just lucky it's just happening because
for some reason and then it took a long
time for Ryan to drill it into me to be
like knowing is actually the work that
you're doing and it is actually new
that's doing that I mean I just said a
moment and I was like yeah [ __ ] you I'm
good at this yeah this is me I'm doing
it and then I just had like a
realization one day and I was like no it
is me
is the work I'm doing and harm or doing
maybe I'll just achieve more I mean it's
that if the cell it's the self-doubt
thing again right and I think um I think
I think it's confidence right when
you're really confident in what you can
do the ability you have it can really
help you level up your game and I think
when you're clearly at that moment and
moving forward you you would have been
speaking to people and you will think I
know in your heart that you are the best
person they should be speaking to in
your market when you really truly
believe that there's no self-doubt
you're not thinking are at the lock-in
month last month like that just sort of
just oozes out in everything do not I
mean people can can hear in your voice
they can even if you are putting on the
smiley astir piece of voices if it isn't
real I feel like people they know that
they know it isn't real and you're
dealing with an industry where hire
managers and CEOs and so on they are
getting me so many people call them a
day that they probably know how to eat
you alive if they can sense that you're
not believing in what you're saying so
it does change massively once you
actually believe in yourself and and I
think there will be a few pivotal
moments in everyone's recruitment career
where they've probably something's gone
wrong
to be honest even ours how it goes on
for me now that self-doubt trickles in a
burglar or maybe maybe not that maybe
it's not working and but then we like a
few people moments were saying really
bad will happen or a candidate isn't
painful or you've just you've lost
control of something and you're like no
I'm going to get it back and you
actually fight for and you get it back
and then you're like yeah that's it
that's me I'll put it back and then you
can slowly come back and I think
there'll be two or three moments in
someone's early recruitment career will
they need to have those months where
they bring it back and then that'll help
them go on for other is the true love
that so just quickly then before we sort
of talk a bit about today and how you
find the things bla bla bla and just
thinking about sort of obviously now you
would obviously the team would have
grown around you
you would have seen obviously been
surrounded by way more recruiters like
and I guess now you your internally be
like a great story right season here was
this solution our first second year now
she's this blah blah blah so I guess you
must see a lot of people around you that
Rossi aiming to get to where you are and
Beyond but may not get there right so I
guess what would have been some of the
maybe common things that you've seen in
others that you think may have had an
impact on preventing them getting there
so you've spoken a lot about what you
did Percy to change and and then you're
living and breathing this that you've
learned that I guess that'd be
interested to get your thoughts on maybe
some of the things that you think of
help people back I think common mistakes
I see some people brand new recruitment
is there they don't listen to the advice
or they don't know not willing to take
on the advice that they're given so
really really simple if you've had sort
of results or someone brand new to the
to the industry that works with you
there are first few months they're
probably gonna really bring to you some
not very good candidates they're just
not right because they're still learning
here and you keep going say no they're
not quite right and then you'll get some
people that will fight against that and
then oh no nobody told me this I'm like
yeah I told you that because he's told
you that but it's not true and I think
you you're very quickly seeing the first
type three to six months people that but
they're gonna be successful the ones
that actually listen to your rice and a
like happy to take it on and not see it
as like a personal dick to them it's not
what you didn't I yeah yeah and then
people that I think some people just
aren't good at taking criticism and
that's not a bad thing but maybe that's
not gonna be right because in this
industry there's gonna be a lot of
constructive criticism all the way for
your career so I've seen the common
things that I see for people that don't
succeed isn't that they maybe don't have
the ability but they don't have the
ability to take on constructive
criticism or even just advice hmm
and I think I think and then I think
that's important for out your career
right because if you're if you're
someone that's able to take on advice
like that's even more important when you
want so you but you finished that second
year had a great second year
obviously you hit your goals blah blah
blah but I'd like to think that you'd be
someone that would still be willing to
take on the bias you know I mean I think
that's so important it's important to
have it bring that your cat critter
because it's really important to say
okay Susan zombie this I'm going to make
sure I do this next time buy my blood
but I think the best people that level
up again and continue to are also
willing to say yeah how about an
absolute great year I finished in the
top three but I will take advice from
that person do not I mean definitely
night all right there's a big there's a
massive joke in there in the office in
the team is I'm really bad at writing
like writing content writing emails I
I'm shocking icon I'm not just not very
good at English literature
alright you know anything at all to be
honest even spelling I'm all for that so
everyone always jokes because I will
whenever someone's ever had any success
on anything I love all can you send me
the email that you send I've got that
response because that's got a really
good response so why would I not use it
so I've got literally got a folder in my
inbox if everybody else has emails that
be successful and the way that I do my
work is I'll just take snippets from all
of those emails because I know that it's
not my strong point yeah spending an
hour trying to write an email when
somebody else has already had successful
one so why not use it I love that so
much so she's still willing to yeah
still willing to improve and learn from
other people right absolutely love that
and okay cool so let's just talk a bit
about well just quickly actually and
before we come to the end I want to talk
about today and how you been getting on
but just quickly but how much does it
helps you do you think beat your
competition being like super niche
because I think you hear all the time so
this comes up so much from the poor
classes and where it's so important to
have a niche have an inch wired Mardy
for whatever and also know will see you
don't know anything different right but
like when I don't know when you've
spoken to the potential clients or
whatever like how is it enabled you or
has it given you a competitive
wanted over others when they might spoke
to other people I don't know what's been
your experience that I've interests cuz
I think that's worth highlighting yeah
massively so like we like we like I said
we know well I know as much I can i
what's color without being a scarlet
developing myself but we know the mark
inside out like I know which contractors
are available which ones I would write
for the job there and then so when
somebody has a when somebody has a role
me in the contract team we literally can
we've got ten fifteen profiles available
there and then to go because they're the
only people that were speaking to that's
all that we're doing on a day-to-day
basis it's literally just speaking to
scarlet candidates we don't have to go
into JavaScript or NATO ever so we know
it off my heart wears if you've got more
than one you can't memorize it all you
don't know it all of our you're gonna
have to go looking for it it's gonna
take a bit longer and also as well like
somebody that doesn't know their niche
doesn't know your market they're just
reworking of buzzwords that's all
they're gonna be doing is working for
buzzwords from a job spec and they
literally just going to puzzle it
together they're not going to know
actually what the project needs what
kind of experience they need with those
buzzwords or what kind of how could they
want they're just going to literally
throw a CV over with the buzzwords that
match whereas we know what that project
is because we've seen a hundred of them
before so we know the kind of people
that you need and we know where to find
them and what companies to find the
problem yeah and I think also back to
your point of how important it was for
you to sort of have complete belief and
confidence like also that also taps into
and how to have more self beliefs and
self belief and confidence because you
know that your competitors what aren't
just doing this and sort of you know as
you just said off by heart and that just
gives you even more confidence that you
know the best profiles no I mean the
mountains is huge and cool so I guess
obviously also I'm sure you went into
like wield their 20/20 best year yet
eight hundred caring be nearly a million
pound bill in this year and the the
universe had different plans
what so how I see as you as you said it
begin elicits if one of the channels you
had it is folks in fact the whole day
but what have you sort of been
in the sort of the market over the last
sort of eight to twelve weeks have you
found it it's not hide in here it's been
it has been tough for everyone and
things have slowed down like there's no
getting away from that and I think what
we have been doing or I have been doing
is again what I have got and Who I am
working with them making sure that they
are protected and you are nurturing that
and doing what you can to secure what
you've got and that was my main thing
before doing anything else was secure
what I've got before trying to get any
for now so it's very much fine it's like
no but if what you've got already
disappears then in you're back to square
one so I very much just kind of keeping
him regular contact with what I've got
making sure that okay if there is gonna
be any hiccups what can we do and then
from that it's just the main thing that
I've been doing is just market Intel and
there's a lot of stuff being posted
online and on job boards and so on but
no one really knows what the truth of
all of that is behind it right now
because because we don't really know who
who's actually moving forward with with
anything so my approach has literally
just been as always keeping in touch
with my contractors and keeps in such a
market and just going off of what is
actually happening with market Intel and
just moves me forward to that what what
so what's been your um it's always think
important to make sure the people where
the the challenges they're facing
they're not going through them alone so
what's been the biggest challenges for
you then since this since this has been
going on for you personally and I think
it's just been the hiring freezes that
we've heard just everyone is they do
need people but they just can't bring
them on right now
tough objection right sir you can't
bring them on right now and which is
probably the truth in most cases it
probably is so the way we've approached
it is just well getting a back up
getting a back up of people that are
available for wait longer like a bench
yeah like a bit like having a pool of
people readily already interviewed
already there to go so even if you can't
get anything
play any
since May now anything close now then
just make sure you've got the back up
there for when things can progress so
how how does that mean that I think you
just touched on it I guess cuz then that
can be quite difficult if I'm the
recruit right now it's like right okay
well I'll keep getting that kid getting
hiring freezes like what should I be
prioritizing you know I mean so I guess
I don't know what have you been
prioritizing each day as you met so you
said marking mapping will market Intel
might be that that so what what have you
ended up prioritizing has it meant that
the whole day you've been just speaking
to people to find things out just as
much kind of nature so much crying so I
don't know what have you ended up
prioritizing what have your priorities
changed they haven't really is the same
there are I'm still I still do have
maybe I'm lucky I still do have clients
that I'm still having to work for and
still find the placements for so I'm
still having to source like are doing
the morning and I'm still talking to
candidates it's probably the only
difference in the BD side of things is
the approach that I'm making is it's
probably a bit softer and more of our
keeping in touch kind of just just
making sure that you don't come across
like insensitive or tone-deaf I think
the way the way that people behave in
this time like this is a global is
affected everyone and I think the way
that you act and behave now will be
remembered for a very very long time and
people will remember yeah remember how
you acted so I think it's important that
everyone's going for the same thing just
be sensitive to what's happening yeah we
wouldn't be remembered for right I think
that's that's such a great thing and
what and what what's really helped you
over the last 8 to 12 weeks personally
so we'll just get through the tough days
because I've definitely had good days
and bad days right definitely
over the last couple of weeks had way
more good days but still have tough days
I guess what what's helped you
personally so I'll just get through
those tougher those wine
yeah definitely one I've never used to
drink during the week I do now but I'm
trying to see it's a sophisticated think
just I speak to my contract team all day
every day we'll have a face time and
sometimes it's literally like 10 20
minutes I've not really fully work but
like it's just having a bit banter like
my I love my contract team it's me and
the four boys and I absolutely love them
like they made my job the best thing
ever and I love salmon and every day we
are so much fun
so just 20 minutes everyday speaking to
them just picks up my mood so I've just
been making sure I'm keeping in contact
and the girls I love little gossip with
the girls for the moaning meet and we
have our coffee the girls I work with
there's always like I'm still somebody's
in recruitment now you're always in a
busy environment like it's constant
noise whatever so I've just been trying
to recreate that I just make it try to
speak as people not just emailing but
actually seeing the faces yeah just just
using those things to make you remember
that you're not alone and it's not a
shoe in your one bed flat to smashed now
and you're not in a silo yeah corn
before I ask you the last couple of
questions I have to ask just because I
think a lot of people will be interested
in hearing Ryan's story I guess what
from your perspective Ben then obviously
at signifier and obviously the the
growth I guess how how has sort of them
runs leadership impacted you person and
you think what's been some of the things
that maybe he's done or just been in
that environment that do you think had
had the most impact on the amount of
interest well I've learned everything
that I know you from him in his
environment so everything that I've
learned and all the sistex success that
I have had has come from him and his
environment so that's pretty much it I
wouldn't have achieved what I've
achieved without his and jaxa Paul and
that what they've told me because I
didn't have anything before they gave it
all to me so yeah I would
be well we're out now without that
environment and I thought he wants to
even say that we recruit learn because
those times when I did really doubt
myself and to say at the end of them but
I can't anymore no it's too much and
then going back in and having the
encouragement from them has kept me in
there so yeah I think I would not be who
are the recruiter daddy
without what Ryan has told me so what
are you most excited about Susan post
postcodes personal professional what you
most excited about holidays get me in
the sunshine
that's kind of like free holidays this
year I should have been in Bali and
Sydney like I had to yeah but trip to
Bali Fortuna bit week seeing my friends
and then trip to Sydney for the first
time and had to cancel that you know
it's that so yeah I think holidays and
just being back in the office like I'd
need to be in the office I can't be own
home my own anymore I'm going crazy
I've been talking to my plant I need a
poster yeah it's a lot last question you
can answer this with a phrase a sentence
of words whatever comes up for you but
if Susan could communicate to every
single recruiter out there they'd listen
to your advice they take it on and
implement it tomorrow what would you say
to the people listen everything listen
to the advice listen to your candidates
and listen to your clients just actually
take in love that season it's been
actually pleasure thank you thank you
having me